Speaker 1: So it's now being alleged that
in that infamous debate between Donald Trump
and Joe Biden during the 2020 presidential
campaign.
Shortly after which it was officially announced
that Donald Trump had COVID.
It appears Trump actually already had COVID
at the debate and knew it.
Now this is shocking in that Trump would do
something so irresponsible that a president
would allegedly hide a diagnosis of a very
contagious disease and risk exposing his opponent
to the disease.
It is shocking, but it is not surprising,
and we all suspected it at the time.
That's the thing, and we're going to go back
to some of those clips.
The report is in the Guardian.
Trump tested positive for COVID a few days
before the debate.
Chief of Staff Mark Meadows says in his new
book, Mark Meadows makes a stunning admission
in his new memoir obtained by The Guardian,
saying a second test returned negative.
Donald Trump tested positive for COVID three
days before his first debate against Joe Biden.
There it is.
Mark Meadows also writes that though he knew
each candidate was required to test negative
within 72 hours, nothing was going to stop
Trump from going out there.
Trump, Meadows says in the book, returned
a negative result from a different test shortly
after the positive.
In other words, Trump found a negative test.
Nonetheless, the stunning revelation of an
unreported positive follows a year of speculation
about Trump.
Then 74, had the potentially deadly virus
when he faced Biden, 77, in Cleveland on the
29th of September.
Remember, Trump announced he had COVID on
October 2nd.
The White House said he announced that result
within an hour of receiving it, and he later
went to the hospital.
Donald Trump is denying it.
Donald Trump put out a statement saying, The
story of me having COVID prior to or during
the first debate is fake news.
In fact, the tests revealed I did not have
COVID prior to the debate.
Now this could be a completely meaningless
statement, and you just break it down into
its component parts and you have to say, Well,
what?
How could would he be saying may be true,
but not the full truth?
When Trump says the story of me having COVID
is fake news, he might be referring to having
symptomatic COVID.
What he might mean is listen before the debate.
I had a positive test and a negative test,
but I didn't have any symptoms and I didn't
really have it until later.
That's what Trump might mean, and he might
be saying that out of ignorance, or he might
be saying it out of calculation.
Trump also says a test revealed I didn't have
COVID prior to the debate.
Write the story from Mark Meadows as he got
a positive test.
Then he took a different test than it was
negative.
And so a test revealed I didn't have COVID,
but one test revealed that you did.
And of course, we all suspected that this
was the case.
As a reminder, it's like it was yesterday.
We had this video when Trump was in the hospital.
Dr. Sean Conley was asked, When did Trump
last test negative?
And I watched this.
I think we had a stream with 60, 70000 people
watching at the time.
We all watched it together.
And his answer made me say, and it made many
of you say that is an evasive answer.
Trump clearly had COVID during the Biden debate,
and he knew it just as a reminder.
Remember this when he had his last negative
test?
Speaker 2: Was it Thursday?
Was it Wednesday?
Don't you remember when he had his last negative?
I don't want to go backwards for people who
are around him.
I understand the contact tracing as I understand
it is being done.
I'm not involved in that.
Speaker 1: So why would you?
Yeah, very, very suspicious answer that made
all of us think that's obviously a lie.
And then this is from this morning on CNN.
Speaker 2: Donald Trump tested positive for
coronavirus three days before his first debate
against Joe Biden on September 29, 2020.
The stunning revelation is in a new book by
former White House chief of Staff Mark Meadows
that was obtained by The Guardian, a positive
test the country never knew about a positive
test days before.
He ultimately admitted to the country that
he had COVID.
Speaker 1: And remember, he didn't look good
or sound good during that debate, and many
of you were saying in the chat when we were
streaming some things wrong with Trump right
now,
Speaker 2: this before attending event, after
event, after event with vulnerable people.
Now there was a negative test the same day,
but it still raises all kinds of questions
about honesty and transparency and timing,
and why the White chose to trust one test
rather than another.
Speaker 1: While he trusted the test that
said negative, obviously for the debate,
Speaker 2: according to the Guardian, Meadows
writes that he knew each candidate was required
to test negative for the virus within 72 hours
of the start time, but quote, Nothing was
going to stop Trump from going out there.
Speaker 1: Yeah, you might also remember that
when Trump, there was the story that Trump
arrived too late to be tested.
But on the honor system, Trump's team said
he got a negative test today, which may not
have been wrong, may not have been a lie.
But he also had had a positive test.
So I mean, it was an irresponsible is an understatement.
And there is the personal and there's the
administrative and policy on policy.
Trump was a disaster on COVID.
We have reports that had he taken it more
seriously, not said fifteen cases will soon
be zero talked about masks.
You know, if he had if he had done all the
right things, a significant number of the
deaths during 2020 could have been prevented
that we know at the policy level disbanded
the pandemic response team.
You guys know all the stories at this point.
Trump also was behaving irresponsibly at the
personal level, and we knew that intuitively.
We knew that when Trump went to a factory
that requires masks, wore no mask, but put
on goggles.
That was weird.
That was irresponsible.
We saw all the personal, but this just adds
yet another layer to it.
And it is not surprising because we all suspected
it at the time.
But it is shocking.
And this is Trump's own former chief of staff
saying it.
Trump with a very strange and narrowly worded
denial.
I believe Mark Meadows, I don't think Mark
Meadows would make this up.
I don't know why.
Mark Meadows would make
this up, and
it
was
what
we
all suspected at the time.